[Music]
hey everybody it's sunday yeah what's
going on turns out that uh damn
cronenberg movie started today we didn't
we didn't realize well it started friday
i think but the only i mean i want to
see it but the only showing is at 9 55
p.m
weird so we're gonna see you tomorrow
night yeah i think tomorrow night we'll
go see it so maybe tonight we'll do
another movie but yeah so
i'm not really sure like so i go in the
room last night and i'm like well we
just need to see a movie like for the
matinee like to talk about tom's like
just for some reason completely at
random yeah man i want to see the newest
spider-man movie yeah
that was good have you been like talking
to somebody about it or not i just saw
it i saw it mentioned on some of the uh
programs that i listened to you're
talking about how good that one was and
how good uh
uh ghostbusters afterlife was
yeah we might have to watch ghostbusters
yeah after life tonight
i kind of wanted to see it at the time
but then like i heard mixed reviews and
we just never got around well there's
just streaming now so you can watch it
yeah you know and uh so
watch this one and uh this is a good
movie
it is and this is coming from somebody
that is usually like pretty meh about
marvel like i like them but like i said
but this one was actually like a [ __ ]
a really good time it was like really
really fun really entertaining it was
just kind of fun it was good as good as
the end of the spider verse i liked into
the spider verse because it's just so
[ __ ] crazy this is the same kind of
deal this is like spider-man's greatest
hits
it's got all the spider-man live-action
spider-man it's even got all the
villains
even like uh you know the original green
goblin with all what's his name
william the faux green goblin is in it
you got jamie foxx's electro all from
all you got the dude from the sandman
you got uh and and then it has
toby mcguire shows up in it you're like
well how the [ __ ] does this happen
well uh
the new spider-man
what's that kid's name
tom holland tom holland yeah that
spider-man
his cover got blown and it was [ __ ]
up his life because everybody found out
that he was spider-man
and and
his [ __ ] [ __ ] was collapsing so he
goes to dr strange
this is quite a premise he goes to
doctor strange and asks him for help
that's he could make everybody forget
who he was
so he's casting this badass spell and
and he kept [ __ ] asking for more and
more during the spellcast and they got
it all [ __ ] up
all right
and uh it allowed all the [ __ ]
villains of spider-man and all the
spider-man from other universes coming
through these dimension doors
and uh i was waiting for like
one of the cartoon spider-man to show up
i wanted to see [ __ ] wouldn't that
have been funny yeah i wanted spider-man
noir to show up and [ __ ] spider-gwen
and spider-ham and spider-man spider-man
because then you'd have live action
characters that go on
there's cartoons in here now there's
cartoons that would [ __ ] be great
it'd be like something why is why is
there a tiny spider pig in here yeah
it'd be like something out of jessica
rabbit or something
and um
but none of the cartoon ones came
through only only the live action ones
came through
and then um
they all kind of round them up
spider-man and
doctor strange round them all up and
they got them in cells
and it turns out that he's going to send
him back
dr strange gonna send him back to their
universes
and uh the
spider-man figures wait a minute hold on
these guys die if you send them back and
they're like don't send us back we'll
all die you know
so spider-man's feeling [ __ ] saw he's
hot soft-hearted character
he steals the damn
magical tesseract box thing i'm just
making up names
that's what it looks like and he steals
it from [ __ ] doctor strange says
don't send him back i'm gonna try to
cure them and change their fate to their
destinies
using iron man technology he's an iron
man
and i'm going oh man this is gonna
[ __ ] this is he's gonna [ __ ] this
[ __ ] up
and have some really good scenes where
he's fighting [ __ ] doctor strange and
doctor strange is making mirror
universes and just ripping holes through
reality and changing and flipping [ __ ]
it makes me want to see the doctor
strange once then because i i was like i
was starting to uh starting to [ __ ]
um have like a i was starting to [ __ ]
like that character you know what i mean
[ __ ] kind of have like a man crush on
his character that was a handsome
[ __ ] sitting there [ __ ] doing
all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's a [ __ ] yeah and
he's saying some [ __ ] and i go
that's a good looking guy there man and
jenny's going yeah he's [ __ ] hot
i said i didn't notice who doesn't love
benedict's coming back
matter of fact this spider-man
they make sure they're doing some
gratuitous nudity with this boy [ __ ]
had him sitting there them girls were
undressing him in the very beginning his
girlfriend or mj and he's [ __ ]
looking good man he's on cycle he's on
he's on that winstrol gotta be uh but uh
if any of you young guys are having
trouble
[ __ ] getting you a girlfriend go
check out that dude right there and says
that's what you should look like
you look like that you're gonna get some
girls all the all the just hit that gym
dude make sure that blood blood
chemistry is correct if you can read
between the lines and [ __ ] in a
matter of a few years you'll look like
that
you'll be able to get a date
anyway
so
spider-man [ __ ] steals the tesseract
they're getting a fight over it and then
he goes on this big quest to try to
heal all these uh and cure all these
villains
and
turns out he eventually gets it done
then i was impressed i was like all
right
uh the [ __ ] a lot of good characters
in it it was fun
um weren't any really slow spots in it
he has a good relationship with all the
other spider-men which that was that was
mine i think that was like the stuff
with doctor strange and the stuff with
the three spider-man like like those
were probably my favorite yeah yeah it's
all kinds of cool because it was like so
cool to see like toby maguire back and
then andrew garfield who played i didn't
see the andrew garfield movies because
they didn't actually they were supposed
to make a trilogy but they only made two
yeah uh it was the amazing spider-man
from 2012 and then they did
uh amazing spider-man 2 and that was
2014 and they're supposed to make a
third one but they never made it but
that's where he came from yeah so i
didn't see those so i was just kind of
like well that guy must be in the other
spider-man movies that i didn't see and
i know who toby mcguire was yep and now
two of the things that stuck out beside
spider-man and doctor strange man was
[ __ ] um electro
j yeah it was a jimmy fallon jamie jamie
foxx
he [ __ ] knocked it out of the park
that was yeah he was a good area
and i didn't see the movie that he came
from so i got to find that movie
it's the first time i saw that character
and then um william defoe man
i love willem dafoe he's so awesome
first of all that's an old man and he
was looking [ __ ] good well now i
think they did do some [ __ ] on him so he
would look more like
he did like because i think they did
that to alfred molina too the guy that
plays daca yeah okay because they wanted
him because the whole premise yeah
the whole premise of the movie is that
they came there before spider-man killed
them like in the old movies so they have
to look like they looked in the old one
so i think they did some de-aging [ __ ]
yeah yeah [ __ ] doctor octopus looked
great [ __ ] and uh they really
kind of upped the game with uh
with uh with the goblin all right i
[ __ ] love that character
with the old toby maguire once [ __ ]
yeah william the phone he's like the
basketball goblin he's [ __ ] quoting
nietzsche and being [ __ ] crazy on his
[ __ ] super soldier [ __ ] serum and
[ __ ]
and uh because i remember him
back when i was watching the cartoon as
a kid you know spiderman spiderman and
they would show the [ __ ] goblin and
he was basically just riding around on a
damn [ __ ] electrolux vacuum cleaner
with [ __ ] wings and [ __ ]
yeah the little [ __ ] coming out of
the van
and they got him hooked up like they had
him back in the cartoon where he was he
had armor on
it had like the armor that you know but
he ditched the mask he didn't have that
he [ __ ] punched it and cracked it
and uh because he was sick of that mask
instead he had this stem he put on this
purple
cloak it was all just torn and it just
had a hood and it looked just like he
looked in the in the old [ __ ] combat
comic books flying around on that damn
vacuum cleaner
it's what it looked like to be
running around
[ __ ]
throwing it down smoke bombs and [ __ ]
this poisonous gas and [ __ ]
and it was just uh
it was a great movie had and it was i
think with the great thing about it is
that uh it was just real fun
really yeah and it was like it was fun
it was action-packed it was like sense
yeah it wasn't crazy it made sense you
know what's you know what's kind of
crazy when i was kind of like reading a
little bit about this because like i
said i've seen some of the mcu movies
but not all of them so i'm not like
we did see uh the the spiderman movie
before this one which is far from home
right we saw that in the theater and i
remembered enough of it yeah that like i
remembered all the [ __ ] with mysterio
and stuff like that so i was like okay
so this because this one picks up like
exactly where that one was right yeah
stopped like right after that i didn't
remember much of that movie i'd be
honest i don't remember much about it
yeah i didn't remember a great deal
about it but i remembered enough about
it to like pick up everything that i
kind of knew but like i said some of the
spider-man's i didn't because there's
like 40 bajillion spider-man movies um
because it's been rebooted so many times
so i couldn't like remember a lot of
stuff
but
so i will say that if you haven't seen
the other spider-man movies you probably
should before you see this one but you
don't necessarily have to yeah i'd only
seen about half of them but it's still
you know i saw enough of them to
understand the characters but i saw the
toby maguire ones which i liked those
and if you saw the tobey maguire ones
that's actually enough
it's actually enough too yeah to
appreciate this movie because this can
actually be a standalone
it was
i'm watching it i'm going to manage you
know what this is basically kind of like
a retelling in a way of into the
spider-verse it was yeah and it's very
much like that yeah i saw some other
reviewers that say that it was kind of
like a live action in the universe
and i think that was a good move because
the end of the spider verse was a really
good animated feature
i loved it i liked it yes that was like
really really good yeah that was so fun
uh in any kind of superhero i don't
mostly don't like mcu move i don't like
yeah like i said they just most of them
just seem very like they're good but
they're just kind of bluff they're just
kind of blue but this one was like super
fun yeah this one was like super
entertaining out of the superhero movies
i like the classics you know classic
superman
um i like the toby maguire ones i liked
uh
the good batman movies you know which
ones i'm talking about there was some
bad ones too you know [ __ ] batman
robin and [ __ ] yeah everybody hates that
one
and um
i really like shazam
i love shazam i thought
and and and i liked uh
i liked uh some of the dc ones you know
venom oh that was that's marvel i think
um yeah because venom turns up because
turns up in this turns up at the end of
this
right here um and then what was the
other one the aquaman that was pretty
good yeah that was dc there's something
about the dc universe it's kind of i
know it's kind of hit or miss some of
them are not really as good as the other
ones but when it came to shazam
there's like a playfulness to it that i
liked i just had fun with it you know
what i mean because it's superheroes
you're not really supposed to take the
[ __ ] seriously unless it's batman i'm
not gonna i haven't seen the new batman
it's supposed to be kind of like a noir
detective flick i think it's going to be
good well they said it was good
i probably like it when i see it
um and they say that the uh that the
joker's making a comeback
that there's going to be a second part
of the joker you know with the one with
the
joaquin phoenix they say that that's
coming back i don't know if it's true
but i heard that
um recently
so that one was real good um
but we'll see this one kind of i kind of
put this one
up there with into the spider verse and
shazam not as silly as shazam but as as
fun as shazam yeah it was just real fun
i mean we just like had a couple
cocktails and we were just sitting
around like wow this is like actually
really entertaining yeah like the whole
just all of it was entertaining i want
to see black adam that's going to come
in that you guys haven't seen the rock
man he's eating 8 000 calories a day
he's [ __ ] huge
he's getting ready you know he's [ __ ]
huge now and or at least he to get to do
that black adam uh
uh uh character and he he looks [ __ ]
big man bigger than he normally does
we'll see
what i was gonna say though was that the
funny thing about this when i was doing
uh
research into this movie
was that the whole multiverse thing that
actually wasn't their original idea they
were just gonna go ahead and like do the
thing but then like the writers it's the
same guys that wrote and directed the
the first two yeah they were like what
if we did something like it's a
wonderful life yeah and they were like
hey that's kind of a cool idea and
they're like okay well why don't we
bring doctor strange in and then we
could introduce the whole multiverse
thing and they actually were just gonna
bring back
the other characters just kind of like
his fan service just like a tease but
then they're like [ __ ] it let's like
make the whole plot around that before
they even asked any of the actors
involved like if they would be in the
movie yeah so but you know luckily
everybody did come back and it all
worked out and everything but i was just
kind of like but that's not actually
what they intended i guess like when
they first started like working on the
movie but yeah it was a great idea
because it really like opened some [ __ ]
up and yeah it's fan service but
you know it's fun so it was fun slides
talking about the amazing spider-man tv
series that was terrible you talked
about the old live-action tv series yeah
it was
but i liked the i liked the uh
the uh the the kids cartoon from the i
think it was late 60s or early 70s i saw
it in the early mid 70s i think when i
was a kid there's one spider-man
spider-man does with it i can remember
that [ __ ]
and there was some some of the visuals
out of spider-man with right out of the
comic book in the in that television
dude in in the cartoon series i liked it
all right if you watch it now it's
probably [ __ ] terrible as an adult
but as a kid it was spot on
i liked it
danny rowling said tom holland's not a
bad spider-man but marissa tome is aunt
may yeah right she's not old enough
although i will say that marissa tome is
older than she looks yeah i think she's
probably pushing 55. she's gotta be
because to be honest with you and i
think i said this to you last night i
was like man marisa tomei doesn't look
any different than she did in the
[ __ ] 1980s yeah well what they did
she doesn't look much older than she
looked like in my cousin vinnie and when
the [ __ ] was that in 1987
what they did was they they went into
that um
into that [ __ ] multiverse thing
you know that one uh aunt may there are
other ant-mates there are other mjs
there's other spider-mans and they're in
this movie just like in the spider-verse
and um
some of them uncle ben die and tell him
about [ __ ] great with great power
there comes
great responsibility but in this one it
was it may that said that that yeah
there was no uncle ben
so things are different in each one of
those universes
and into the spider verse the
and it was all animated it was in an
animated universe you had uh miles
morales was spider-man yeah and then um
then there were other spider-man some uh
spider-man noir was
a detective back in the 40s in a black
and white comic book all right he's in
it and then there's a then there's a
spider gwen actually was the my fav one
of my favorite characters out of the
spider verse i thought that was a good
character yeah spider gwen we was a
female ballerina who was bitten by the
spider it was cool costume she had a
little
hoodie on and stuff and um
then there was another one um
what was another one oh they had the one
that was an anime girl yeah and then the
spider mecha in the spiderman yeah yeah
that was a good
round ball with spider legs on it and
it's about the size wasn't even it's
like he had this fold up to get in it
yeah it was a little spiderman
it was a much different way like i said
spider ham spider ham who looked like a
little porky pig basically porcupine
like a little porky pig but spiderman
yeah so some
[Laughter]
comedic comedic hero comedic characters
and stuff can be spiderman it just
depends on what universe they come from
and out of the multiverse which that's a
cool concept that means you can have
you can have movies
about any kind of spider-man that's in
the multiverse and they're all
recognizing one another
in this movie some of the [ __ ]
multiverse spider-mans now know each
other but i think they were forced to
forget weren't they
yeah they came back well yeah because at
the end they actually did succeed in the
spell yeah to get it all started to like
forget so so i thought though that like
when he first went to doctor strange and
asked i thought he was only asking make
them forget that i'm spider-man
but
after the spell got [ __ ] up and
everything like that like when they got
to the end it somehow got to maybe i
like misunderstood but um somehow it got
to no they have to forget you forget
that they know you
you know what i mean so pretty much like
everybody forgets
who like everybody that he knew before
and stuff like that like doesn't know
who the [ __ ] he is now
so yeah that was that but he like had to
do that like to save everybody so
but yeah i i agree that like introducing
the whole multiverse concept especially
to
something like spider-man that has had
so many different iterations and so many
reboots and stuff like that so you can
really play with all this different
stuff like oh well all the movies yeah
it was all different actors and all
different [ __ ] happened but it's like
that was just in a slightly different
universe and they're all kind of
interconnected you don't have to worry
about you don't have to worry about
continuity mind right as much because
they're happening in parallel universes
so that's like a really weird writing
your way out of the problem sure
you'd make that part of the story and
especially for something as sprawling
like as the mc mcu or you know the
marvel movies because there have been so
many and they do it i mean those cycles
that they've had lately they do seem to
try to maintain all the continuity i
don't know who the [ __ ] has to keep
track of all that stuff but bless them
because i don't know there's holy [ __ ]
they must have like [ __ ] just spread
sheets and like [ __ ] boards and like
red string and all the [ __ ] going
everywhere i couldn't keep track of all
that [ __ ] to be honest with you but
you know maybe they just have like
little modules or everybody keeps track
but there's so much like overlap that
somebody's got to keep track of all that
stuff now they're saying that jamie foxx
electro that was from the same one that
had the sandman in it so i've said okay
i've seen it i just didn't remember yeah
because salmon was in this too yeah it
was a long time ago i haven't seen those
in a long time
yeah i know that that other that other
spider-man i've never seen that guy
that's that's from another little he was
from yeah the 2012 and 2014 one like i
said it was supposed to be a trilogy but
they never made the third one yeah okay
um
but yeah like he's familiar like i'd
seen him in other things but i did in
those two movies but i didn't see he's a
british actor too is he isn't that crazy
they can act
and they can do american accents
well i was like doctor strange uh
benedict cumberbatch he did i he does an
american accent in this very many good
drama schools in the united states you
know to get in the hollywood movie is
just how you know who you're going to
blow yes
actually i don't know i don't know if
andrew garfield is british i think he
was born in the united states but then
he moved to the uk and studied over
there yeah so maybe he doesn't have a
british accent i'm not really sure i'd
like i said i've seen him in other
things but i didn't see his spider-man
movies and i think i saw the tobey
maguire ones yeah i did see the toby
mcgarrett ones that was like a really
really long time ago so i didn't like
really remember a lot of stuff oh and
the lizard was in this too yeah the
laser yeah i don't remember what briefly
came from
yeah that might have been the same
i don't know yeah now i can't remember
he's well he seemed to know electro
right so they must have been from the
same that must have been the same
universe right
i don't know if they had anybody from
the andrew garfield ones because i don't
know like what villains he fought like
in his he said he fought some russian
guy on a
oh that's right yeah
on a robot on a roll you guys have
cooler villains right rhinoceros
right i don't know what he was talking
about we meant to look that up because
i'm like what the [ __ ] is he talking
yeah
yeah because he was talking about how
much cooler like the villains were and
and then like tom holland's spider-man
was being like he fought he was you know
fought with uh the avengers and he went
to space and they were like what what's
an avengers yeah
yeah they didn't know what the avengers
were and they were like ooh badass he
would just bathe and all this other kind
of stuff uh there was a is that a band
[Laughter]
yes yeah
in that universe it doesn't exist so the
writing so you know really the main part
of this
has good special effects acting was the
main thing was the writing the writing
was really good
the story was really good that's why
this one shines
a real good uh
real good tone uh
just
fun and adventure
and crazy [ __ ] happens but it all makes
sense
i mean that that sequence was doctor
strange doing all like where where
spider-man like traps him in the mirror
universe or whatever that looks super
cool he really likes that a lot so the
whole movie kind of ends up being like a
spider-man greatest hits
yeah and there's nothing wrong with that
yeah it's got all the best characters
live-action characters from spider-man
in it
so
goblin comes back william the phone
goblin comes back the [ __ ]
doctor octopuses back sandman electro
the lizard guy is in there dr strange is
in there and then at the end venom's in
there the venom's in florida at the bar
getting drunk fighting with himself and
[ __ ] over the dead
[ __ ] over the bartender he's got his
wide shirt on trying to run from new
york
yeah like they do i did like the venom
movies yeah i mean tom hardy yeah yeah
he's a national yeah so venom's running
around here somewhere
yeah so yeah i think that'll be really
good but yeah and it actually made me
want to see
the doctor strange movies yeah you know
what i mean right yeah i could see that
now at what point i think we're just on
the second one too i think there was a
doctor strange and then there's the one
that just came out yeah the multiverse
of madness or whatever i think that
might still be in the theater it was
playing the last it just started like
the last time we went to the theater
yeah um marissa tomei made her debut in
toxic avenger of all things says
strawdog 78 yeah that's right she should
have been in the sopranos yeah uh no on
the sandman electro sandman was in
spider-man 3 and elektra was an amazing
spider-man
one or one or two okay so elektra was in
the ones we didn't see okay
lizard was in the first amazing
spider-man okay uh danny rowling said i
kind of hate that the modern spider-man
has a mechanical suit given to him by
iron man which is kind of cheating in my
eyes they took it away from it yeah he
it he did get it taken
he loses it mr 88 says the robot rhino
was introduced at the very end of
amazing spider-man 2 and was supposed to
be the villain in his amazing spider-man
3 which they didn't make okay yeah at
the end of the movie he's uh the suit's
gone he's just uh he's back to the this
old
red and blue
[ __ ] leotard type thing yeah he's
back to that to the classic look
which that that's that's the way he
should look if you ask me
yeah i mean you know i kind of feel like
it would be more into that yeah
you know have an ironman technology like
you said
it does seem kind of cheating because it
seems like iron man technology can do
like pretty much everything unbeatable
yeah it's like what do they call that on
tv tropes whatever technology or it's
just kind of like whatever you needed to
do and it's like oh it'll do that you
know now this is what's going to happen
if you all know the lore i don't i know
it in general but i don't know you know
i didn't read all that [ __ ] you know
what i've been editing
if venom is in florida it's only a
matter of time before spider-man gets
infected with venom
because that happens in the in the comic
books i mean i kind of feel like well
in the little bit yeah i mean i'm
talking about like the like this movie
because i assume that everybody that
wanted to see it this end of marvel has
already seen it so i don't give a [ __ ]
if i spoil it or not yeah it's not like
it just came out it was like last year
they all know but um yeah so at the very
end with eddie brock yeah and he leaves
a little bit a little bit of the venom
goo like on the bar did you notice that
and it was like so yeah that's going to
like come into play peter parker is
going to come in there and he's going to
get or it's going to get into it and
eventually end up inside parker
yeah because that happens in the comics
right yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] peter parker gets affected
with it and they they they're a symbiote
for a while
and
in the comic books that was for like a
long while
yeah i seem to vaguely remember yeah
like i said i'm not real big on like
reading the comics but i do remember
being in comic stores and seeing stuff
on the cover he fights it for a while
and then eventually it gets into him
i think it started off as a suit or he
thought it was a suit or something i
don't remember exactly it was a black
spider-man suit and then over time it
took him over
and it was venom
but i don't remember exactly how it
bastard it's a long time ago tammy said
bruce campbell should have been in it he
was in the tobey maguire spider-man
movies yeah that would have been cool
maybe they couldn't get him yeah i mean
he could have turned up in there why not
uh mr 88 said by the way decidedly not a
marvel fan but just recently watched
most of these with my sons okay that's
that's fair enough well like i said i'm
not i'm not i don't i'm not [ __ ] on
marvel i don't hate them it's just i
don't usually
i've seen a bunch of the movies but i
don't usually feel the need to like rush
out and see it and i'm not real up on
all the lore like i know enough of the
lore to like enjoy the movies and pretty
much know what's going on but i'm not
like one of those people that every time
like a minor character walks through the
background they're like oh [ __ ] it's
that person you know what i mean so i'm
not like totally geeky about it jay and
i kind of agree in general
when it comes to marvel
when you watch them you have a good time
watching them yeah and then a few hours
later you've forgotten everything you
saw yeah they're very temporary they're
not nothing really stays with you
they're not they're not really story
driven they're it's more like visually
driven it's kind of like being at a ride
at disneyland
and then once it's over you quickly kind
of forget about what happened they don't
really stay with you
they're kind of shallow
they're not yeah but they're just kind
of i mean when we saw this one and i was
like well i remembered that we had seen
the one before this one far from home
because i remember going to the theater
and seeing it but all i remembered about
that movie was the end with mysterio
like where he fought mysterio and i
remembered that it's like weren't they
all like on a high school trip to europe
or something like that okay so i
remember that about it but then when um
when this movie started i was like oh
yeah that's right everybody found out
that peter parker was super it was
superman was spider-man uh and so that
was what but that's really kind of all
you had to know because that's literally
all i remember from the second movie
you're taking your kids to see uh marvel
matt take him to see
show them shazam
[ __ ] shazam used to be on television
sly prior members it used to be on
television we used to watch it all the
time man it was a good series you could
probably watch it for free
but the movie shazam that came out i
loved it and uh the second one's coming
up
black adam is coming up and i and i
think shazam is in it if i i know that i
know that in in the shazam universe
shazam and black adam
meet each other
they're both superheroes they're i think
they're good guys but they're different
he's from what i remember um
but no he'd probably like shazam
that's good
and that was that one's just more about
magic superheroes that have magic
they're not even going to say they're
not going to give you excuses like
radiation spiders and [ __ ]
no it's [ __ ] magic alien magic
all right i mean why not might as well
yeah look at all the [ __ ] doctor strange
can do yeah
he's basically just a [ __ ] wizard
yeah i mean you know yeah that's awesome
with ultraman which is a japanese
[ __ ]
superhero
that was where the first time i saw
these superheroes it was a [ __ ]
aliens gave this japanese friendly
japanese man a [ __ ] little baton i
always used to [ __ ] steal the [ __ ]
thing out of the toilet paper dispenser
i was a little kid that holds the toilet
paper roll
thing that was my [ __ ] that was my
[ __ ] ultraman that's so cute yeah
he'd say some [ __ ] into that get big
he's totally a toilet paper yeah yeah my
mother before where's that [ __ ]
toilet
i'm not there turning into [ __ ]
ultraman i turned into ultraman goddamn
yeah
and the first time i started watching
that he got big i was like oh man this
is a godzilla movie this is back in the
70s out in california i was a kid you
know
oh it's like a godzilla movie he's
fighting all these aliens alien monsters
all the time ultraman
it is better than superman it is
basically the story of superman all
right in a kind
uh but he gets big
all right that's how they topped the
american market you know our superman is
big he's not just superman
he's [ __ ] ultraman he's better than
yours
okay that's where they were coming with
it so now we should counter with like
uber ultraman yeah
yeah well shazam was kind of like
ultraman but he didn't get big he you
know he just
he just he just became an adult because
he's a kid yeah when he comes in to turn
into an adult i kind of feel well it's
really weird because i kind of feel like
a lot of those like japanese movies like
superhero movies they they always have
like a hero that can get big yeah well
they gotta get big because they have to
fight like caillou some giant yeah they
gotta fight some giant [ __ ] we reviewed
big man japan did yeah big man if you
guys have not seen the movie big man
japan get it please watch it yeah um
it's like a hilarious it's like a parody
it's almost like a mockumentary yeah
about a guy
who is like a japanese superhero who has
to get big yeah to fight because he's
getting big and everything i got to get
big yeah
and he's unemployed and [ __ ]
it is so awesome
i love that it's just like so [ __ ]
funny the whole premise is so funny to
me
well i think what makes it funny is that
the premise is zany but it's done like
almost completely straight faced yeah
which makes it like 10 times funny when
he gets big he doesn't have a special
suit he's just like a big sumo wrestler
in a [ __ ] little glowing cloth yeah
like the sumo and he's like lumbering
through the town like fighting all these
crazy looking monsters
and it's like and it's about like a it's
like a documentary career like making a
documentary without him yeah like it's
supposed to be like top secret that he
does this and it's just oh my god it's
like it's delightful i i [ __ ] love
that movie yeah i think it's on 2b
actually for free might not be but it
was a while back yeah now they're
talking about how spawn would now we're
having [ __ ] superhero fights and [ __ ]
between
you know
characters that have magic or demonic
powers and then you have [ __ ] then
there's there's [ __ ] going between
marvel and [ __ ] star wars star wars
is shot man star wars is so [ __ ] up i
don't think they'll ever be able to put
that one back together that's what
happens when you
put novice [ __ ] directors and writers
and [ __ ] onto a [ __ ] old property
that has a [ __ ] legend and lauren
fans they're gonna go in there and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] up now there is some good star
wars movies that were made like rogue
one was good
first couple
first couple seasons of mandalorian are
pretty good now has anybody been
watching the obi-wan series it's
terrible um because i haven't like i
haven't like really looked to see it
they say it's terrible oh just let me
just say it's just nonsense
it's still you know i mean they they
[ __ ] that up you have to control you see
that was the good thing about marvel
the mcu they at least kept all the story
lines straight and they're in
the marvel
canon you know what i mean they but not
star wars star wars is [ __ ] just all
over the place
and evidently they did the same thing
with [ __ ] star trek
like [ __ ] they say star trek is just
[ __ ] terrible
um like uh star trek picard is supposed
to sucks
now they're doing uh uh [ __ ] the one
with pike and some have said that that's
pretty good
um but i i don't think i'd get into that
i'm not gonna [ __ ] pay see
20 bucks a month for cbs so i'm just
[ __ ] [ __ ] cbs
you know start on get that [ __ ] bootleg
went on [ __ ] dvd [ __ ] when it's
all over it says popeye and underdog
were my first superheroes as a kid yeah
mine said probably now that i'm thinking
is here who's in here that's there's a
lady
hey what's up liam
how are you doing yeah
mr idiot says japanese have to get big
sounds like phallic stereotypes
[Laughter]
that's why well i don't know that's why
i thought that like big man japan was so
funny because i've seen like a lot of
those old japanese movies and i'm like
they always have to have the hero that
has to like who that has to like get
really big like to fight the monsters
and stuff and so the fact that it's just
like some schlubby fat guy that like
lives in a trailer or some [ __ ] and he's
like every time there's a monster he's
like oh i gotta go get big you know hey
aaliyah
ali you know it's gene love jezebel at
will's pub this friday coming up
yeah you might want to make that
although you know you know what's his
name's going to be there nick's going to
be there probably he's going to be there
so you know
well we're going i already bought
tickets i'm going we got tickets i
already bought tickets actually i should
probably
yeah so so the side tracks show this
week we're going to move the side track
show to saturday because we have to go
to will's public early because the show
starts kind of early yeah but i think
well dj maniac was here earlier and he
said like some band that he knew was
opening for them but i don't think
they're opening for them here here i
think it's um rose garden funeral party
yeah is opening for them
so yeah so are we done talking about
spiderman yeah uh slicing he liked rogue
one yeah i like rogue one too and i
thought
the first uh uh what was it uh force
awakens i thought that was gonna be
something but then the second one came
out now i fall and then the third one
was like oh [ __ ] and that was it i was
no i was done with [ __ ] star wars i
was like nah they don't know what
they're doing now mandalorian came out
in the first two seasons it was good it
was good
uh but then it's disney you know what i
mean [ __ ] we we know people that have
worked for the disney company and know
their mentality they're it's just
they're [ __ ] up company they're not
gonna they're not gonna uh
they they they can't do
good star wars they would resist it they
they're gonna want to do it their way
and their way is gonna [ __ ] suck
you know and it doesn't sell toys
you know only the good [ __ ] the [ __ ]
that i said is good is selling toys the
[ __ ] that i said is bad is not selling
into the toys so it's not just me all
right i can i got a good taste in star
wars i know good star wars when i see it
most of the [ __ ] disney makes is star
wars fan fiction it just doesn't have an
authentic feel to it
and that's the same thing with some of
this star trek i've been seeing you know
like nah i ain't star trek there's no
[ __ ] sonar in space there's no sound
in sp [ __ ]
it's just because they got dumb people
writing it original star trek had smart
people but they got dumb people writing
it that don't know that sonar can't work
in space because there's no sound in
space
it's not some creativity [ __ ] or
anything like that it's not it's not
artistic license no they're dumb
and that has been confirmed by
people around that writing crew they're
just dumb
mr 88 says marvel is disney too yes it
is yeah but they got people that know
the marvel universe and
who are doing it right but they don't
have that with disney as with uh
okay the problem the problem with
[ __ ] star wars is that they decided
that none of the extended universes can
and they don't want to use it because
they don't want to pay the royalties
well most of star wars
is extended universe all those books and
games and [ __ ] like that that the fans
love and as soon as they said we're not
going to use that then they've just
thrown most of the [ __ ] fan base away
that's just how it is
you know
and because most of it was
most of it was extended universe and it
was good with the extended universe
was good well written
so there was no reason to throw it away
had they made movies about the extended
universe they'd have made a [ __ ] ton of
money but they didn't want to [ __ ]
spend their spend the money on royalties
so [ __ ] them
danny rowling says uh which film is
better the film gacy based on john wayne
gacy or the spike lee film summer of sam
well she didn't want him um summer of
sam i actually remember that being
really good i think i saw that in the
theater and then i think i saw it once
afterward and i remember really liking
it gacy i think i saw
a long time ago but i don't really
remember anything about it so i'm gonna
say summer of sam just uh just on merits
of like i remember it better you know
what i mean so
all right and then we can so we can talk
about that on tuesday because i
i was thinking about it last night and
i'm like i bet that [ __ ] [ __ ]
started because i remember seeing the
trailer and they said june sometime and
i said well it's middle of june so i
checked and then they were like yeah it
is playing thankfully at our theater but
that's the only showing they're not
doing any daytime showings it's all at 9
55 p.m
so yeah but i want to see that but
probably tonight we'll watch
ghostbusters after life and unless we
think of something else like in the next
couple hours i don't really know but
yeah so
thanks for dropping by and hanging out
with us talking about spider-man today
and uh have a good rest of your weekend
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
evening
bye